what's that it's a book of scary stories  some people believe if we repeat stories  often enough they become real they make  us who we are  that can be scary eat it Harold  [Music]  do you want to see haunted house  some kids went missing so they boarded  it up  okay I saw it we go now toward the  chicken  [Music]  what's that it's a book of scary stories  tell me a story  hey what's going on  Tommy's missing Tommy's name was in the  book there's no way it's actually  connected right okay what happens in the  book is exactly what's happened for real  oh my god listen you're in the next  story reading it right here I'm afraid  that we broke something up you shouldn't  have taken the book  we've got to stop it  sara bellows his book when the stories  write themselves and it all comes alive  the jingling man is coming  you  you